I once heard that tragically have
described as Canada's house band and
that's absolutely perfect
[Music]
couldn't get you all from pop I grew up
in a world where he was part of the
framework with what The Tragically Hip
did was create this background that we
were able to grow up within and and you
know that's really rare
not only has gordoni showed us what it
means to be Canadian and it means to be
an incredible songwriter an artist but
he also showed us what it meant to be a
great person
the pilots artists and musicians and you
know activists - he's out there doing
what he does best - country I'm huge hip
fan I've been a hip fan so long I don't
know many Canadians that part yeah so to
have that news hit I was shocking to
chefs
he defines Canada really well right now
he's been an inspiration and kind of a
soundtrack to the whole trip and
Hollywood board has written songs that
have hearkened to all of the significant
events in our lives as Canadians for the
past almost two and a half generations
whether it's the exhilaration of the
wedding or a graduation or at a concert
or in time upon say we remember hip
songs take us back and our chemic cut
stones to these significant events in
our lives
Gords influence knew no bounds and they
were successful where it meant the most
we know what they're all about we love
their music and if you don't get it fine
with us
we all love Gord and so it's not an easy
thing to wake up to
he's one of Canada's most important